Leonardo DiCaprio pulls a hilarious  prank on Jonah Hill Leo was spotted  lunching with a few of his buddies in  NYC's West Village on Monday the actor  returned to the Big Apple after spending  weeks overseas and took a stroll around  the city with some pals Leo spotted his  wolf of wallstreet co-star after leaving  the restaurant and seemed to be in the  mood to play a few tricks Jonah was  minding his own business on the sidewalk  when Leo came running toward him like a  crazed fan and appeared to scare the  daylights out of the 32 year old actor  the Oscar winner seemed to record  Jonah's priceless reaction on camera  once Jonah realized the man was Leo  pulling a prank the two laughed and hug  it out but the best part is an actual  fan snapped a selfie with Jonah shortly  after while Leo played it cool